because the dream of America is so
incredible but it's got to be a legal
process but it's not even the dream
that's being sold to them anym it's just
the IDE you're being offered free stuff
now you know what I mean this is not the
American dream and I'm suffering so much
in this country and I'm willing to
Traverse through the desert uh for an
opportunity like you said it is now
systematic you are going to have a
better life as soon as you get here it's
all set up for you you know I met a
journalist that found the dumping point
where they're being told to dump all of
their IDs they're coming in on flights
from other countries dumping their IDs
because they're being told to she had
three bags filled with their IDs and
then they handed these pamplets from the
UN by the way which was beyond Bonker
she showed me this pamphlet that was
coming from the UN and they're being
told to do this to come into this
country because they know that there are
politicians that are setting up an
entire system for them where their lives
will be better so this is not the same
the same mentality people that are
coming at the border right now we have
to let go of this idea that they're just
these suffering people who are willing
to do anything for an opportunity
they're just being offered handouts